Chris asked Gary would you support being
our employees writing their own books
and curating their own content streams
and personal brands Chris is a great
question as a matter of fact first of
all India first let's talk about Chris
bribing you and like attacking you let's
go over here to India and you tell the
vaynernation though the vaynernation
the story of actually while you're doing
that while you tell everybody chris's
attack and bribing i actually gonna
bring a prop for this that's fine i'll
be right back
Trouty alright looking for the
microphone for India's story Chris it
was extremely persistent over the
holidays a lot of people were tweeting
questions and he got his friends to
tweet after his question and tag me and
then he said that he might start bribing
me so it definitely worked here's your
question on the show it didn't work
because you didn't text you didn't
execute the the actual bride gift right
you went Noble but now Chris I want you
to know and we've known each other a
long long long long long time and it's
good to have you on the show that you
will need to send India gift it will
need to be substantial and we will tell
the vaynernation what you got her in a
cup upcoming episode and so you know
this is really your chance to either be
a good guy or a terrible guy try to you
do me a favor can you find me Jason
Donnelly he he was going through his
he's floating around he was going
through orientation yeah cool we will uh
we were looking for Jason Donnelly and
we will answer Chris's question with
Jason Donnelly as a human prop to your
question let's go to the next question
I'll interrupt that question when Jason
Donnelly shows up that's how we're doing
it the rock don't fight me d rock let's
move on
alright here we are to finish off this
answer this is actually tremendous
timing because the question came at the
same exact time that Jason rejoined
vaynermedia Jason you made the vital
devastating mistake to leave vaynermedia
and go somewhere else but then you've
rejoined Boehner today why don't you
tell the vaynernation first just cuz I
want to hear it and feel good about
myself about why you did that but just
one sentence because I want to actually
answer the question this is hope that's
it alright you I figured you could
answer this question better than I did
so why don't you tell the vaynernation
how I did support somebody who was
writing their own bucket not only did he
support me by just loving the book he
bought copies and gave it to people
throughout the office and he's been
nothing but helpful and the curt best
boss ever thanks go work you got to make
a lost time the bottom line is of course
you know I think that you can't get away
with saying you're gonna take care of
people and and you want to build around
them too many people want to act like
they didn't take care of everybody but
then suppress people who they think can
trump them see there's something amazing
that happens when you think you're the
greatest of all time you don't think
that anybody is necessarily gonna be
able to surpass you that's you don't
need to supress and I mean that I mean
it may sound like a douche bag thing to
say but like I believe so much in myself
that there is no value in me trying to
hold down people that I think are more
talented me than me and that happens
every day of the year in organizations
all the time and so for me show them
show them for me if they're better than
me or if they need to fly the nest well
then that's what needs to happen if that
means writing their own book and
building their brand I'm more than happy
to do that and support it I just believe
in fair and in capitalism and and so not
only do I believe in supporting it I do
support it actively when it happens oh
crap wait subscribe I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many right
hooks in social so subscribe
you